Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
the book of
the book of seeking forgiveness, seeking
pardon from Allah.
The author mentions the third and final
verse. He cites the third and final
verse of surah which we discussed
yesterday last night
in which the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said
instructing
the prophet Allah says instructing the
prophet sallall.aii
Allah says,
"Then
glorify and proclaim
the perfection of your Lord and seek his
pardon and forgiveness."
Notice
how Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala made
seeking the forgiveness of Allah
something that is to be done after one
has properly and fully glorified Allah.
So it is we glorify the perfection of
Allah and we seek forgiveness for our
imperfections because what is a
Subhan Allah.
When a person says subhan Allah, they
are essentially saying Allah is free of
any imperfections.
But then when a person turns around and
says
I seek Allah's forgiveness, what are
they saying about themselves
that they are very imperfect?
They are proclaiming the greatest of
distances between themselves and Allah.
Allah is free from any imperfection.
He's perfect in every way. And I am
imperfect in every way. And I seek
Allah's forgiveness for those
imperfections because perfection will
only come from Allah. He is the author
of perfection. He is the owner and
sovereign king of perfection. None is
perfect but he and so I seek forgiveness
from Allah.
And then Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
describes himself saying
that indeed Allah verily is ever
forgiving and accepting of one's repent
repentance.
He is forgiving and accepting of of
one's per repentance.
So this verse was revealed and it said
this is the last chapter of the Quran to
be revealed altogether.
That the final and last chapter to be
revealed as a full chapter altogether
is surah nas. And this was revealed
a few weeks or a few months at most
two months before the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam passed away. This
is one of the last things that were ever
revealed. The last chapter to be
revealed is
He will f
and the last verse to be revealed
is in
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
and prepare care and fear a day when you
all shall be returned to Allah. And upon
such return, each shall be recompensed
his full measure
based on what he or she has earned with
his own hands, and none will be
oppressed on such a day. And so we
notice that when this chapter was
revealed,
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam was
narrated by
Muslim to have never prayed a salah
after this chapter was revealed.
Once it was revealed, every single
salah, he was overheard in saying
in every salah after this chapter was
revealed because he knew that he was
coming close to his death. So he was
preparing for his death.
And what's interesting about the
placement of this chapter
is that comes right after which surah in
the order of the mus
right
is very very harsh and very very clear
in its dissociation from the
disbelievers.
Say, "Oh disbelievers,
indeed you do not worship what I worship
and I will not worship what you worship,
etc.
To you your actions and to me my
actions." A person may say, 'Well, if we
don't try to bridge the gap between us
and the disbelievers,
if we don't try to make ourselves
relatable to them, then how will Islam
spread the very next chapter?
Don't worry about that because people
will enter the religion of Allah in
droves. They will enter into the
religion of Allah in droves. Not because
we are relatable,
but especially because we are different.
That is what draws people to Islam. Not
because we are just the same as everyone
else, but because we are positively
different in every in every meaningful
way.
Look at the innovations that have
accumulated over time. The innovation of
unifying the religions and it said the
Abrahamic religions
meaning the Jews, Christians, and
Muslims. We're all Abrahamic religions,
right? Or said divine revelation
religions.
So, we're all really distant cousins at
most and brothers and sisters at best.
Right? That's the idea. Who has ever
entered into Islam based on that da? No
one. Absolutely no one. Why would you?
Why would you? If the if Islam is being
presented as just everyone else,
we're exactly the same. There's nothing
different about us. You may see us on
the outside. We look different, but
we're really we're just the same as you
guys. Then what's so special about you?
Absolutely nothing.
That's not what brings people and draws
people to Islam. What draws people to
Islam is its difference. It's unique.
It's bold. And it is un
and and it has no shame or shyness in
the controversy of being different. It
thrives on that difference. And the more
we proclaim our difference and
clarify
the aspects that make us different, the
more what happens, the more people are
drawn to Islam, the more people will
enter into Islam.
[Silence]
Hallelujah.